- They said yesterday
75% of the people dying
have four comorbidities, meaning
they're pretty sick people,
and that many of them
are dying with COVID,
as an incidental finding.
All right, he came in,
he lost his arm, his leg,
and his ear was cut off
from an automobile accident,
and he also tested
positive from COVID.
But he died from internal
bleeding, but he also had COVID.
But see, when they're
waking up to it,
and when you have
CNN doctors saying
cloth masks are nothing more
than facial decorations,
guess what?
Maybe yeah, they are,
I think, understanding
that there are more
deaths under Biden
than there were under Trump,
that they've got some
explaining to do,
and their best way
is to explain this
as something we're going
to have to live with.
(gentle electronic music)
- I'm Dave Rubin,
and joining me today
is the junior Senator
from Kentucky,
the man that Anthony Fauci
has endless nightmares about,
and now I think
it's fair to say,
a Rubin Report regular,
Senator Rand Paul.
Welcome back to
the Rubin Report.
- Well, thanks for having me.
- You had quite a day
today, another fight,
or what do we want to call it?
Fight?
What do you want to call it?
I don't want to call it fight.
But you got into it with Fauci.
- Let's just call it a brawl.
- What do you make of
this guy at this point?
- It's just like a
verbal brawl, yeah.
- And you keep coming back
to personal attacks on me
that have absolutely no
relevance to reality.
- Do you think anybody
has had more influence
over our response to
this than you have?
- [Anthony Fauci] Let me finish.
- Do you think it's
a great success?
- [Anthony Fauci] Madam Chair.
- Do you think it's a great
success what's happened so far?
Do you think the lockdowns
are good for our kids?
Do you think we slowed
down the death rate?
More people have died
now under President Biden
than did under President Trump.
You are the one responsible.
You are the architect.
You are the lead
architect for the response
from the government, and now
800,000 people have died.
Do you think it's
a winning success
what you've advocated
for government?
- Senator, first of all,
if you look at everything
that I said, you accuse me
of, in a monolithic way,
telling people what
they need to do.
Everything that I've
said has been in support
of the CDC guidelines.
Wear a mask, get
boosted, get vaccinated.
- [Rand Paul] And you've added
to it to make it coercive.
- Take a look at everything
that I have said.
- And going forth, you've added
this is to be done by mandate.
You've advocated that
your infallible opinion
be dictated by law.
I've always been pro vaccine.
I'm just simply against
authoritarianism
and against mandates.
The anger that's developed
with you, Dr. Fauci,
is that you don't want
to give us advice.
You want to tell us what to do.
You think you are the science,
and that anybody
responds to you,
how dare you, how dare
you criticize science.
As if you somehow are science.
That kind of
arrogance, that hubris,
is really, that's where the
anger's coming towards you.
If you were one doctor
among hundreds of doctors
in the government who gave
advice, I don't think anybody,
people might object
to your advice,
but there wouldn't be
such a degree of anger.
But you are so certain
that you're right
that you're not wiling
to hear anyone else.
Three epidemiologists,
of which you are not even
an epidemiologist, but
three epidemiologists,
prominent in their field,
Oxford, Stanford and Harvard,
you maligned them.
You spoke openly with Dr.
Collins and you did not disagree
that let's paint them as fringe.
You went after them and said
we will do a public take down,
not in Science or
Nature or Lancet,
in Wired, in The Nation,
a left wing publication.
You've engaged in base politics.
You wonder why
there's so much anger?
You're not an
objective scientist.
You've lost that long ago.
And so many of the
things that people want.
They want to know
why you're forcing
their children to be
vaccinated when 95%
of people at risk
have been vaccinated.
Over 95% of people over 65.
It's a huge, voluntary success.
And yet you won't
rest until you force
every child to get this.
So yes, there's a great deal
of dissatisfaction with you
and many people want you to go,
but nobody wishes you violence.
Now, I think he
deserves everything
he gets and then some,
to tell you the truth.
I mean, we've probably never
had a government bureaucrat
have this much
power over our lives
and this much disdain for
our individual liberty.
And really, when you've got
a government bureaucrat,
a government doctor who believes
and will tell you
that I am the science,
and any criticism of
him is basically seen
as criticizing science, can
you imagine the arrogance?
Today he went one step
further and he says
if you have the
temerity to question him
over him going after
these epidemiologists
that wrote the Great
Barrington Declaration,
if you have the
temerity to do that,
you're now guilty of fomenting
violence against him.
And it's a terrible sort
of accusation to make.
And I reminded him that look,
I was there on the ball field
when a Bernie Sanders supporter
almost killed Steve Scalise.
A staff member was shot
less than 10 feet from me,
but none of us blamed
Bernie Sanders for that.
None of us really
said, oh, you can blame
a left wing politician for
some crazy supporter of theirs.
And yet that's
what he did today,
and the left wing
media lapped it up.
- So knowing that
the left wing media,
which is basically all
the mainstream media,
isn't going to frame any
of this in an honest way,
it does seem that the
narrative is collapsing
for the people that
are paying attention.
That a lot of the stuff that
you've been talking about
for quite some time is
starting to bubble up.
They're sort of admitting
you get the vaccine,
it doesn't quite work
the way it was promised.
The masks don't
work like promised.
The lockdowns don't
Are you feeling that there
is an actual momentum shift,
and what do you think
that will look like
at a national level, if so?
- You may have seen this
in the last year or two,
that some people suspected
that the death count
was inflated, that
many people were dying
with COVID and not from COVID.
Wow, the Biden administration
has woken up to this fact,
and we're getting
regular pronouncements
from them day to day.
They said yesterday
75% of the people dying
have four comorbidities, meaning
they're pretty sick people,
and that many of them
are dying with COVID
as an incidental finding.
All right, he came in,
he lost his arm, his leg
and his ear was cut off
from an automobile accident,
and he also tested
positive from COVID.
But he died from internal
bleeding, but he also had COVID.
But see, when they're
waking up to it,
and when you have
CNN doctors saying
cloth masks are nothing
more than facial decoration,
guess what?
Maybe yeah, they are,
I think, understanding
that there are more
deaths under Biden
than there were under Trump,
that they've got some
explaining to do,
and their best way
is to explain this
as something we're
gonna have to live with.
- How much of the negligence
do you think, at this point,
trickles up to Biden,
and I'm saying that
specifically that way that
it trickles up to him,
because I don't think he
really has a good handle
on what's going on
here, but you know,
we've all seen the videos
a month or two ago.
If you get the jab, you're
not gonna spread COVID,
et cetera, et cetera,
you won't catch COVID.
That's obviously not the truth.
I mean, what has to happen
to some of these people?
From Biden to Fauci to
Walensky at the CDC, et cetera?
- If it's trickling up to
him, it would have to be
mashed and made
for edentulous food
that you feed to the elderly.
I mean, I don't
think he's in charge
of a whole lot of things.
I would say that he's
indirectly responsible for it
because he did say
over and over again
he was gonna not lock
the economy down,
he was gonna lock
the virus down.
And now more people have
died under his watch.
He did blame President Trump.
He said he's responsible for
these 200,000 people dying.
It was a ridiculous statement.
No honest politician
should have been allowed
to get away with it, and the
media should have gone at him
and said that's not fair.
And yet the media bought into
it and it was the narrative,
that the virus
was Trump's fault.
But now as the virus
goes on and seems to be
really uncontrollable
and the deaths mount,
now it's sort of, well,
you need to accept it,
really the cloth
masks don't work.
They're trying to find a
way to get back to normal
because guess what?
The blame's attaching to them.
But almost all of the
things that you see
are from government
planning, government policy
and socialism.
They're in charge
of the testing.
They're the ones that are
mandating how we do the tests.
So everybody's
got to get a test.
So if your five
year old's got COVID
and you really wouldn't know it,
but you test them and
they've got COVID,
now you've got to
test the whole class.
Then you've got to test
all their siblings.
Then you've got to
test all their parents.
So this thing sort
of spreads out,
its tentacles spread
through society
and the government will say,
oh, we're not for lockdowns,
but we are for
testing everybody.
If you test everybody,
inevitably it leads
to a lockdown.
So this is a real problem.
Most of the people in the
hearing today with Fauci
are like, oh, why can't the
government make more tests?
I'm like, why the hell are
we ordering so many tests?
This is about ordering
too many tests
and it's about testing
people who are not sick.
People who are not sick
should not quarantine,
and people who are not sick
shouldn't be taking tests
or medicines.
We should leave
them the hell alone.
But that's our real problem.
And who gave us all this advice?
Fauci.
You know, so Biden's
taking Fauci's advice,
but Fauci is the problem.
- So, I mean, I think I
know your answer to this,
but should Fauci
should just step down?
I mean, it doesn't seem
to me that this is a guy
who should be running
the NIH anymore.
I mean, enough's enough already.
- I mean, if we don't have
room for him in prison,
I mean, stepping down
would probably be okay.
But no, he's a
menace in the sense
that he really is careless and
callous towards our liberty.
His first impulse is always
an authoritarian one.
But he also ignores the science.
So by conservative estimates,
over 100 million Americans
have gotten this.
62 million, on the official
website, have gotten COVID.
But the NIH has studies
that say five people,
for every person
diagnosed, there's at least
five people undiagnosed.
Let's say it's only one or two.
We still get to well
over 100 million,
and maybe half of America
has been infected.
If you don't count
them, then you think
we're woefully
short on vaccines.
Then you mandate it on children.
But the other thing there,
you would never know
this by watching CNN
or any of these other networks
that are full of fake news,
if you look at how many people
have been infected naturally
and you say, well, how many
people have gotten the vaccine?
95% of people over 65
have been vaccinated.
It's even higher
if you go above 75.
The voluntary vaccine has
been an enormous success.
But if you watch CNN,
you think, oh gosh,
nobody's been vaccinated.
The truth is the opposite.
Almost everybody that's
at risk for this disease
has been vaccinated.
The children are
getting it naturally,
whether you vaccinate
them or not.
Now adults are
getting it whether you
vaccinate them or not.
Really we're headed towards
where there's going to be
enough immunity
within the community,
and I think the devolving nature
of this is towards a cold.
We have four other
coronaviruses that cause a cold.
This is going to become
the fifth coronavirus.
The sooner the better.
And then we also at
the same time will have
some people dying,
the vulnerable people.
Let's try to save them by
getting government obstacles
out of the way so we can
have more monoclonals again,
and more of the new pills.
But also let's repurpose
some of the things
that we have out there
that lessen inflammation.
- I want to shift a little
bit to the big tech thing,
and I know you're on
a time crunch here,
but just one or two
more things on this.
First off, obviously
you've been talking about
libertarianism and individual
rights and the constitution,
all of that old school stuff,
for years and years and years,
and your dad before you.
Are you sort of shocked
how this COVID thing
has unmasked so many
of your colleagues,
people that you maybe had
political disagreements with,
but that just went
so all in on just
government,
government, government?
- I guess I'm not very
excited about having
some snot-nosed punk
over at Facebook
or over at Twitter
or over at YouTube
decide they're going
to judge the science.
It took a little bit of effort
to get to medical school,
it took a little bit of effort
to get to one of the better
medical schools in the country.
And I got some kids who's lucky
if he has a journalism major,
who's lucky if he ever
took a science class,
doesn't know what
organic chemistry is,
telling me that I'm
promulgating misinformation.
So it's really insulting.
But also on another level,
on a very personal level,
these people despise us.
We are the deplorables to them.
We are the people who
live in flyover country
and we are the people they
would look down their nose at us
with contempt, so why do
we give them our content?
This is what makes me
mad about conservatives
and libertarians.
They're all complaining,
saying, oh, I hate big tech
and we should break them up.
No, that's a big
government solution.
Quit using them.
If we all quit using them,
we are 40% strong, at least.
We're maybe closer to
50% of the country.
If we quit using Twitter,
we can topple them
instantaneously.
Just my shift to Rumble, I
think is having an effect.
But I'm one of maybe 10 or
20 prominent conservatives
and libertarians up here.
What if we all did it?
I think we really
could have an effect.
And the thing is is
I don't want people
to make money off my content
who look at me with contempt
and say, oh, we don't like
this, we don't like that.
You can't publish this.
Oh, you said this
on the Senate floor?
Sorry, we're not going to
let you say that on YouTube.
So yeah, I don't
want to be associated
with close-minded people.
- So to that point, you
officially have announced
that you're moving all of
your content to Rumble.
But it wasn't just that, you
did something kind of snarky.
You basically said
I'll only use YouTube
to attack the
policies of YouTube,
which I thought was a
pretty beautiful thing.
I should just say for
full transparency's sake
that everyone knows
that Locals, my company,
merged with Rumble, so
I have some interest
in Rumble obviously.
Is there anything the
government should be doing
related to any of this?
This is where the
libertarian/conservative divide
always goes.
We discussed it once
or twice before,
but is there any room for
the government at any level,
break them up, anything?
- I'll listen, but I'm
always sort of hesitant
to believe the solution
is the government.
I'm also a big believer in
unintended consequences.
The more you look
carefully at a subject,
when the government
gets involved, the
unintended happens.
One of the arguments
big tech says
for not taking away liability
is that if you take away
liability protection
that big tech enjoys,
what they'll do
is become more censorious.
They will censor more people
because they don't
want to be sued.
And there is some argument
for saying, you know,
Dave Rubin called Rand
Paul this on Facebook.
Let's sue Facebook.
Well, that's ridiculous.
I mean, if we're calling
each other names,
either quit using them,
don't listen to them,
turn them off, or call the
other guy a worse name.
But if we get involved
with lawsuits,
and people say, well, what
about the old fashioned,
the established media?
And here's my answer.
Give them liability
protection too.
Instead of taking away,
and this is sort of
an outlier position, but
instead of taking away
liability protection,
give it to the newspapers
and the broadcast media as well,
and I would go one step further.
I would also let newspapers
and television organize,
the bad for this is collude,
but I would let them organize
to try to set the
prices for their content
for YouTube and Facebook.
The big complaint from old
media is they take our content.
We hire reporters and writers
and we put all this money
and effort into
writing up the news,
and then it's stolen from us
and used by the big tech people
who don't pay us
for our content.
Well, let all the
newspapers in the country
get together and negotiate
as one entity with Facebook.
So there are ways
around some of this
that are creative thinking
to try to equalize
the playing field, but
I've never been for
oh, so and so has less
regulations than this company.
Do you want to equalize them?
Let's lower the regulations.
Let's don't increase
the regulations,
do you know what I mean?
Let's try to lower the burden
to equalize opportunity
and access to markets.
- So last thought, just
tying the COVID thing
and the big tech thing together,
I mean, do you really sense
that the future of America
is just gonna be sort
of parallel societies?
Red states will operate one
way and, say, people like us
will operate on
alternate platforms
that will not be the
mainstream platforms,
that everything is sort of
splitting, and I would argue
maybe that was the genius of
federalism in the first place,
and it's all okay.
- Yeah, well, particularly
when you federalize government,
you have the different levels,
you can kind of
move where you like.
And you know, if you're into
the San Francisco lifestyle,
you can live out there and
it's whatever goes goes.
If you want to live
in the Bible belt
and it's less accepting,
and in a small community
in Oklahoma for that
lifestyle, you live there.
And I think some of that is
good because then we can have
sort of freedom of choice, of
lifestyle and everything else.
We already have it a
little bit with marijuana
and things like that.
In the more accepting
states, it's allowed,
the other states
it's not yet allowed.
And so people can
kind of gravitate,
and the smaller the
denomination of government,
the more freedom you can
have because, you know,
if it's a whole state, it's
expensive to leave the state,
but if it's just your town.
You know, remember
when we had dry towns.
It was actually dangerous,
not that I ever did this,
but you had to drive to the
other town and then back.
Of course, some people
would open their bottle
on the way back, of course,
and that was a problem.
- Not that you ever did this.
- You had communities, and I
know you never did that either,
but you had communities that
sort of made these decisions,
and people could choose to live
in the community they wanted to.
And probably the smaller
the denomination,
or the smaller the size of
the government, the better.
- Senator, I know you
have to continue your day
of smacking around Fauci, either
in the media or in person.
I appreciate your time,
and I hope to see you soon.
- Thank you.
- If you're looking for
more honest and thoughtful
conversations about politics
instead of non-stop yelling,
check out our politics playlist.
And if you want to
watch full interviews
on a variety of topics, watch
our full episode playlist,
all right over here.
And to get notified
of all future videos,
be sure to subscribe and
click the notification bell.